[Music]
the first live show of America's Got
Talent was jam-packed with talent
including fourteen-year-old standout and
how he's golden Buzzard
Courtney had way
[Applause]
I was like nervous when I went on the
stage and then when the music come for
an hour I got into the music now is less
nervous but then when singing when see
in the audience stand over give me that
bit more confidence right
I think I came it just be ogre music you
know she is meek and she is shy and she
is that 14 year old girl little girl but
as soon as the music hits she's
possessed and there's a come from I
don't know but it comes from deep inside
her soul and it is like Janis Joplin
reincarnated it's a wonderful amazing
thing to watch what was it like to be
have a front-row seat to that magic well
I was saying to someone earlier on you
know like I've done these shows a long
time and they've been moments whether
it's Kelly Clarkson Leona Lewis Carrie
Underwood cray Seattle Grace Camilla and
always remember that one performance
where you go that's gonna make a
difference and that was one of those
moments it was incredible
so you're calling it right now she's
gonna win the whole ding thing I think
so I'll say it right now she's gonna win
the whole thing
[Music]